hey everyone Oh Star Wars last Jedi has
finally arrived and without spoiling
anything this movie was so tense there's
just so much to talk about guys and we
here at New York sirs are here with our
in-depth review heck yeah hell yeah hell
yeah this is the need to know new rock
stars weekly deep dive in all the
biggest news this week and because Star
Wars is the biggest story this week
we're just gonna spend the entire
episode talking about it
analyzing the parallels to other Star
Wars films and some of the details that
you just really need to know by the way
hi I'm Erik Bosse and joining me here at
the table are Sam basher over here and
then what Garrett your table Thomas
Michael Bechtel out on parole I'm ready
to mingle they won't tell you if they
are also guys as a special treat for you
all we're doing a special giveaway we
got a bunch of free copies of
Battlefront 2 ready to give away to you
to stick around to the end of the video
for the details on that when I couldn't
tell you now these you might stop
watching we want you to watch this whole
thing it's a trick okay again our dog
story is Star Wars the last Jedi we all
saw it
we have opinions about it we will at
some point discuss some of the twists
and surprises that happen in the movie
but we will warn you before we do that
but just to cover our bases just
consider this video spoiler review now I
think we should begin our review by
discussing some things we loved about
this movie this movie was unexpected it
was so unpredictable and I kind of loved
that and it kept the whole thing
exciting because even though after you
we done talking about it we'll realize
some of the plot points are quiet
unnecessary but it was still exciting to
go there because I mean I actually
thought the force awakens was very
predictable and the moment when you know
kylo Ren is fulfilling his destiny by
killing Han Solo sorry it's all spoilers
happening here I actually didn't feel
anything because I saw it coming a mile
away but in this one my goodness I
didn't predict any of these things
happening yeah it was yeah super
unpredictable I was sucked in I was I
was there I'll just say because I'm
well now I got this shirt but I'm not a
huge Star Wars fan there's parts of it I
like I mean who doesn't I don't know
anyone who just hates Star Wars films
I've just never been fully invested this
is the first time in the theater where I
was like its opening with that x-wing
fight of him taking down the turrets I
don't know why an x-wing fight has never
taken me in before but every beat of
this I was into of course his problem so
totally agree that there's we can poke
holes all over the place but I loved it
I opposed story was my personal favorite
his arc was really interesting Laura
during they did some really smart things
with her and I was surprised at what
they did Mark Hamill might be my fate
that might be my favorite performance
he's done on-screen yeah I love his joke
and I love his voice acting work but
that's my favorite on-screen performance
of Mark Hamill yeah before the force
awakens like George Lucas set him down
and said listen they're doing more
movies and they're doing it without me
so if you don't want to do them totally
fine just let me know any straighter I
was like I am signing up sorry ready to
reprise his role there were some hiccups
actually with this particular one
because I don't know if you're in
agreeance with me at all
a lot of Luke's behavior seems really
uncharacteristic like yeah as as someone
who basically gosh and returned the Jedi
did all of his training solo by himself
and had this master plan together to get
Han Solo back like the whole thing was
so well done for him to be a recluse
just because he you know saw that his
star student was kind of going to the
dark side a little bit and he was a bad
uncle like that to me just didn't feel
very authentic at all but the
heartbreaking part was that Mark Hamill
actually went to Rian Johnson with his
complaints and said I just don't believe
that Luke would do this and it didn't
matter
yeah eventually he just said easy I just
had to trust Rian Johnson with this
vision for me it worked yeah there was
part of me that like I mean he's just
seen Lucas it's like Jedi Master but I
mean even at the end of the force
awakens it seems like not all was
totally there there's that look of
confusion and I think it worked really
well in this movie because I think a big
theme of it was like letting the past
die right you know and I think that
applied on a meta level to like we have
to like let go of our idealized visions
of these legends in these heroes and
look at the vision to the idealized way
that we think the stories are supposed
to go like it and I was
think of him like oh man why we never
seen Luke Skywalker be like a master
Jedi I'm like yes we did like we did we
saw they that was there was one more
movie where he is that and it's a bummer
you don't get more of it cuz you always
want more ice cream of course but like
in this it was like when you got to when
you got to where he's at and why he made
that decision how much of it was just
human error or things that were already
going and he didn't he found out of it
at the very last stop he didn't he had
nothing he could actually do at this
point there he does need to take
responsibility for and he does and he's
guilty and brooding and you know doing
his thing Bruder and she mean yeah
without spoiling anything just from the
opening scenes of the movie they do such
a good job raising the stakes of it I
feel like this is the most dire of the
Star Wars stories the most like scared
I've been for the actually this is the
end this is the and and they kind of
raised the stakes from the opening
frames of the movie so the whole time
you're really worried that like the
people we love I think the first act
like you're so right they just kind of
Luke Skywalker was super sassy I
basically
from the get-go disagree with every you
know but I saw full disclosure this
movie at 1:00 in the morning so I stayed
awake
thanks cocaine and it's cocaine mixed
with sweet tarts I know I love the eye I
thought it it surprised me I was texting
with the French I said this was like the
first movie that made me feel like star
wars movie in a while maybe feel like a
little kid where everything actually
came as a shock to me and I thought that
the characters were I mean like it's
tough because carrie fisher's
performance as as general Leia is so
different now than it Princess Leia
which is people age and they get older
and like cocaine again but it's it's
just the Luke thing was funny and I like
I don't know I don't I don't know if
this is too small but I like it they
kind of like ended like fan speculation
on things so abruptly in a couple of
different moments where they're like you
spent so much time agonizing over what
this means or what's gonna happen next
and it is actually pointless to what the
real story is so I don't know I really I
liked it I don't I didn't have much to
add I was just mostly just smiling and
agreeing with you guys it kind of turned
it more from a fantasy at movie to a
warmer because it they're the stakes
were really high in it for a second I
got the same anxiety I had in Dunkirk
where I was just like this is everyone
coming in and it's just this like last
little resistance right and there's
there's really nothing you can do right
now
it's Deus Ex Luke coming in and like he
likes any any kind of barely makes it
work like he barely likes leg is able to
hold it off and then I really felt for
that and everyone made adult decisions
like yes again taking a lot of fan
speculation throwing it out it's just
like no let's make them humans again
they're not a space Jesuses it's just
people and that mean that should
actually mean more to you when you watch
it it was very similar to media like
Star Wars now I was really thinking
about this all day to day and also
there's just some there's one fun thing
I want to point out
I freaking like fully getting spores one
thing I really loved we shouldn't do
anything yeah yeah okay so when we do
that I have one thing I want to get yeah
I would agree with you like this to me
is kind of how Harry Potter wound up to
like the eighth Harry Potter movie is
just a battle for like the entire movie
is that just like and so many things
that are these like put on a pedestal
these stories of these characters of
like how are they gonna find like how
are they gonna get resolution it's just
like they die and I think that's what
happened in this movie a lot were they
like well we got to figure out how this
person can get their like glory or
revenge or whatever it's like nope
they're just gone yeah don't like it
there's a very mature attitude toward
death in this movie like casualties
mattered when characters died like we
see how that is a setback to the war
effort it's not just like I'm gonna go
out in a blaze of glory just to win this
battle it's like know sometimes it's
worth it to step aside and to take the
loss like failure as we've learned from
the major character moments movie
failure is important that's the most
important teaching tool is to fail and
to let on L and show up on your record I
love the fact that you know there are
quite adult themes in this but it's also
MIT and quite well I personally think
with the childish humor it's fine if
people didn't like this movie but a lot
of people are criticizing the humor and
say it doesn't match up with Star Wars I
thought it'd be honest every other humor
point in other Star Wars movies that's
like a 38 II when I get 30% of time I
think it's funny in this it was like 85
to 90% the humor works really well
there's definitely jokes I'm like a game
you were being pretty like comedic Elise
nah be about a movie that invented the
term nerf herder yeah and I there's I'm
okay talked about things in the opening
frames of the movie but like there's
just a really fun Poe interaction mobile
the way force awakens open the way Poe
just kind of undercut the seriousness
and that kind of set the humor tone for
the whole movie they do Brian Johnson
does a similar thing in this movie that
I'm just like I'm on board I'm like okay
they get this sense of humor they get
the balance of this I think the
difference there between the force
awakens and the last Jedi is and I'm not
digging on John boyega as an actor at
all I actually think it's a great actor
but they almost
of Lent into him to be the comedic
relief character and it didn't work some
of the times like he will do something
really quite subtle and it's so great
and so he'll double back on it and like
oh go over the top whereas they put a
lot more eggs in Poe's basket yeah for
Oscar Isaac who I think is a brilliant
actor who really nails his comedic
timing and that back and forth with
domhnall gleeson who's trying to be
strong direct and so happy it goes so
far that it's also you could tell Donald
is also having fun like being like being
full space not so yeah he's just like
he's he is comic-book video game villain
and he loves it and I love that and his
interactions with Kylie were really good
to Kyle oh they took a lot of the
tantrums he'd have in the butt when you
got gave him him his time to play with
ray to like the actors to like those who
have to play together it really it you
understood where he was coming the whole
point of this movie is to make everyone
make sense in real terms and he made
sense by the end of it does he still
have tantrums yes and I guess that's
what we just have to deal with but like
a moment where Luke's like you know you
didn't understand driver about he's
character comparing him to a brooding
teenager and he disagreed with me
completely
he's like why what makes him a brooding
teenager Oh Mike well in the force
awakens he struggles to figure out his
identity he often feels rejected by
everything he rebels against everything
and he killed his dad like that is he
did also like wreck millions of dollars
worth of equipment you know someone said
no to him you know I mean adults really
shouldn't do that if you didn't know
that don't do that well commanding
officers definitely shouldn't do that
there is also a ton of like great visual
choice in some movie that we will be
getting to in our breakdown of it I love
the use of color and this movie I can't
wait to really watch it
um let's actually move on to this
section we're gonna talk about some of
those surprising twists of the movie
this is definitely one of the twistiest
stars movies if you don't want to
haven't seen it you're still somehow
watching this video skip to this
time you know save yourself the trouble
let's go watch the movie there it is I
all right so let's talk about some of
the the bigger twist of this movie and
there I put a bunch of options for us to
talk about to me I I couldn't talk about
Leia's almost really it wasn't that she
was you know coming to terms with her
force that was obviously always within
her I just didn't I didn't like that she
was just super Moaning herself through
space and they could have done a
different way for that that kind of took
me out of it a little bit and was almost
I guess I was just wondering why they
need to do it why couldn't they just
have Leia be on a different part of the
bridge or in a different room and then
some of the residual like debris or
shrapnel or something causes cause some
kind of thing that needs to put her in a
coma they intentionally put her out and
space and wanted to kind of add a new
rule to the world of how force abilities
can work including keeping herself
animated in space and moving yourself in
space that was another positive I
thought of the movie not this scene but
what they did with the force and I'll
get into that in a second sure I was
fine with it because as a very casual
fan I'm like did we ever like talk about
it Leia like she can sense Luke but have
they ever like done anything like this
it was like and maybe in the past what
30 years she's at least tried she at
least tried once was it perfect no
because it kind of reminded me remember
Santa Claus and night before Christmas
when he's like flying around it was like
it was when he was like flying around in
the chimney f that's what it looked like
to me I was like well she'll go back in
the spaceship she look like she was
incinerated before that right fire you
were saving right oh not for Leia but I
didn't want to bring this up for Luke's
scene when at the end he comes out with
kylo a movie reviewer that I love to
watch he pointed out if you watch his
feet don't move the salt on the planet's
surface and it but you think he does
when like
cuz he's getting like a barrage of layer
lasers hitting him so there's not a lot
there but when he starts to move around
if you look there ryan johnson little
tiny detail he doesn't actually affect
the environment that he's in like that
and the way when it worked backwards
once you figured it out like that movie
did a good job of like hey plot holes
we're gonna cover these up and we're
good like this this end off when we get
into that conversation like I have some
thoughts on it but like at least it
airtight plot wise of what he did I
interesting yeah so I want to bring that
up I just thought it was someone pointed
out to me I think I want to share it
because that's a really fun detail to it
I kind of like the notion of and we have
seen this and this actually stays true
to Star Wars that you kind of get a huge
like you can access a store of the force
from within when a you're about to die
or when you know you're going to die
yeah and that it is applicable with Leia
and doing a superwoman and with Luke and
also I guess applicable with Vader who
was able to kind of send off his message
in Luke's dying you know arms dying in
his arms like maybe he should have been
killed in that explosion I don't know I
think that that could be a reason that
Leia was soaring through space yeah that
the explanation of the force in this is
the only time I've ever understood what
the force was I like I tried to read
like Wikipedia articles on it and then
when you go to the prequel stuff you
just kind of everyone throws it away
yeah it went but like even that is like
it's magic it's not like it's not a
thing and in this it's like no this
works is the same as gravity works it's
the way like it's just how things move
and work in this universe I'm like oh
chlorines know right ever of course not
they lack into a religion a spiritual
fantasy thing as opposed to it so cool
for me I was like oh it's literally
people who can just tap into a deeper
meaning of the universe not like like a
D&D thing where it's like magics another
aspect of it it's like no this is how
the universe works I've never seen
saying this excited about Star Wars ever
nice I liked it yeah like the movie yeah
and I let's also just give some credit I
know this is actually it's not as
clear-cut and it's pretty debatable the
reveal of Rey's parentage which was such
a huge ink Tommy you kind of alluded
this earlier of we all were wondering
who raised parents are some people were
convinced
it was gonna be luke or that she was
kylo ren's brother but her sister right
or brother I think it's uh I thought was
a bold move by Rian Johnson to say no
you know what she is a nobody and that's
okay and that's something that she can
react to like by taking some of the
preciousness by taking that question off
the pedestal it was such a good
character development moment for her it
really made me think oh maybe she could
join Kyla right now like he could give
her the answer she wants before the the
one question she wanted is who are my
parents are they ever coming back to get
me and just by taking that away from her
and helping her realize that it brought
her to this new place maybe now he is
the answer to her and for a second I
thought she would be joining him which
was when Luke when she first comes to
the island and he's like who are you and
she's like I'm nobody she actually said
it great yeah and he's like no who are
you and it's like I'm on looks like me
like come on who are you you're someone
who what who do you belong to who
yeah she's not nobody I mean yeah that's
it should mean more to that she's nobody
it should mean more you know what I
wouldn't have enjoyed it as much if it
wasn't for that gorgeous moment right at
the end in the stables where the boy
uses the force that paid off one of my
least favorite parts of the movie that
almost made it worth what we went
through is that final I I think it was
put in the script to set up that final
shot
yeah because otherwise yeah it did feel
a little weird and yeah I think they
were just trying to set up the idea of
the new generation of Jedi and
resistance fighters I think just to put
a cap on the Rey's parents think that's
still not definitely closed in my
opinion but you know like I feel like a
lot of snoke's kind of exposition that
he was doling out while he was getting
ready to you know make kylo kill ray so
he thought it was he could have just
planted all of that into both of their
heads you know what I mean like like
it's really just like she's trusting
kylo Ren like she's like you know the
true he's like you know the truth and
she's like they were no one he's like
that's right they were drunk they traded
her for parts yeah yeah
midship they took off in maybe but so I
mean I don't know I would like it if
they just leave it at that but it being
Star Wars I wouldn't be surprised if for
there's like some specially the thing
the third movie JJ's taken aback my
favorite clips and do the debate was
like when are we gonna figure out what
cool person turned into supreme leader
snoke and it turns out it doesn't matter
he was just like I mean maybe the other
material like other like source material
and comic books and extended universe
stuff we'll we'll go deeper into it but
it turned out he was just a bad guy
right you can actually check her channel
I did another video kind of explaining
that other big twist of Kyllo deciding
to kill Snoke and what that means and
why he didn't how it was both parallel
to return the Jedi but also different
and yeah I really do believe Snoke was
just there as a step for kylo to become
the true villain of this trilogy not as
this mysterious man behind the curtain
yeah I really like that it doesn't I
mean they even brought it back around
that it doesn't matter that he's some
big person that it's that Sith and Jedi
are gonna exist no matter what we do
like cuz the kid at the end that means
Jedi out there and so by that logic sit
exsist too and he just came up and maybe
he had a teacher maybe he didn't doesn't
matter because the stories about kylo
andrade would be him his thing his I
thing I don't know I don't know what's
wrong with them but like beautiful face
yeah let's move on to some of the gripes
we might have had with movie yes we
loved it clearly but it's not a perfect
film so what do we think are the biggest
things holding this film back from being
perfect Casino Royale star like the
George Lucas clauses that all these
movies have where they're like you could
have my movies but I get three moments
in each one like the weird like direct
sea dragon tail sliding back into the
water yeah yeah it was you
comedic li-like it's a comedic moment
but it's also so comedic we presented to
you yeah do you think Lucas snuck into
the studio's later my weak points two
characters that had been set up for so
much potential and then they were taken
away without really being fleshed out
very much at all and that's Captain
phasma and Snoke yeah they you know I
wanted to learn so much more and the way
that the first movie was said about was
that was going to be a knowledge nugget
that we were going to get satisfied and
I feel real bad for Quentin and Christie
because that first in the force awakens
that should have been her versus being
in that battle I'm outside Mass katanas
palace I forgot about that meme like
maybe four or five lines of dialogue and
it's just like I really hoped for so
much more and then yeah the snow extinct
if he is all-powerful and he has been
manipulating and manufacturing ideas and
planting them in his protégées head I
would have loved to have discussed if
maybe a little bit that he was somewhat
like the kind of stiff master that knows
that The Apprentice
that that dynamic is that the apprentice
either gets killed or kills the master
like I would have loved to have explored
the side of it a lot more but it's like
he just had his big line of dialogue
finally said a little bit about it he's
all-powerful and you're like man I mean
it's probably the coolest scene in the
entire movie yeah too busy clapping
cheering and crying but yeah looking
back I was it's like could have we could
have seen a little bit more yeah I
didn't bring this up but also the two
things I loved action throughout action
is the most amazing Star Wars action
period and because it's just these wide
shots where there's no cuts that's just
them doing it it's amazing and then the
the locations they had especially Luke's
island it was like in the background
you'd hear the pores or you'd see the
sea creature it was just like this isn't
the whole world it's just a corner of it
and that's all you get to know it's like
one of those weird Galapagos Islands or
something like all the puffins live
there and it's like it'd be gross to be
there because it's just
only puffins but it's like it makes
sense and blue milk walrus there's a
great he's like he basically drunk it
from Skywalker followed in the grand
tradition of obi-wan Kenobi and Yoda of
becoming like bat nuts crazy ice elated
they're alone and they're just kind of
quirky like yeah it gave us green milk
tattooing I wonder who's getting milked
over on that planet
yeah it's a Red Mill concrete
[Laughter]
okay so here comes thing the fans were
gonna go crazy about Liotta the yota
thing was super weird that was super I
liked what Yoda had to say and that's
not what the problem is it's the puppet
the puppets the problem I love the
puppet
I love the puppet in Empire Strikes Back
okay this puppet was not manned by the
same person it was like it's what I do
when I get a sock it's like he did look
like he was trying to hold a little old
he died in continuation but he also
doesn't like his bones aren't just
barely moving around in his nose but
I'll see your ghost look like whatever
you want or maybe that doesn't work in
your age you grew up on prequels Yoda my
favorites the flippy one no I'm gonna be
honest I really do I do he did look a
little funny he was great he looked a
little funny there was nothing wrong
with young people going to harass him
bastard go talk to me about this in this
room we if you want to complain about a
stupid [ __ ] we complain about the fact
that a ghost gets tired and has to sit
down we're gonna continue talking about
all the things we loved and things we
didn't love it because this whole
episode as he knows devoted to last Jedi
so let's actually move on to our next
segment our weekly trivia question so
one thing that people are definitely
talking about with the last Jedi
is the classic Star Wars running gag the
line I have a bad feeling about this it
is in every Star Wars movie but where is
it in this movie we're still looking for
it Rian Johnson insisted on Twitter that
the line is in the movies harder to
where I got to rewatch it some people
are saying that bb-8 says the line for
series of speeds judging proposal
reaction to the line when we wait for
the subtitled Edition we'll figure out
soon when I every watch it 20 times but
for now our trivia question is for Star
Wars episodes 1 through 7 and rogue one
name the character who spoke the line I
have a bad feeling about this
in each movie ok all the questions are
in
all the answers and later in the show
we'll reveal the answer the person who
gets the most right will do our sign-off
good buy something in the show and do
whatever dumb voice or amazing character
tank Thanks
tank is an Odin sleep right now tank
sleep you know the loser will have to
read our in other news wrap-up headlines
and be hilarious on the spot right
afterwards alright let's continue to
talk about the last Jedi specifically
one thing that made this film work was
the way it embraced I think some of the
stronger elements from another classic
middle chapter in Star Wars trilogy The
Empire Strikes Back if the force awakens
was designed to echo a new hope I think
the last shot is definitely the
spiritual grandchild of Empire I thought
we would go through and do it by
comparison segment here to compare the
two films and the points where they
parallel each other and maybe talk about
which film is a better middle chapter
the better middle chapter of puppet last
night did not look like that that's a
better puppet that's a better puppet
they got they picked up one in a store
because they wanted to do it last second
I'm standing by this yeah I think I do
agree that in pretty much every way
Empire trade maybe it's just a classic
and it's impossible to top this movie
explain again like a ripper from the
movie Luke says it's impossible - when
he finds out his dad I think one thing
that last shot I might have over Empire
is so there's this plot point of the
hero traveling to a remote location to
train with the Hermit Jedi a notch - and
in Dagobah I think the scenes with Rey
and with Luke I examine the force and
explained it in a visual language in a
way that and none of the movies have
done before what is the force and then
you had a few training montages or like
training expeditions and both of them
demanded to be trained and was knocked
back straightaway initially yeah like I
pretty much preferred you know I'm going
through this backpacking is like no I
have to okay I have to look up to Yoda
like this Jedi Master you know realizing
that that's actually him music I cannot
teach you I mean what I loved that
moment
much more than no I'm not gonna teach
you the lights every moment was actually
pretty good but everything else did you
really make sense the white thing was
the best like yeah the most heightened
the end of episode 7 and everyone's like
I thought we really had a like a mirror
scene of lifting the x-wing out of the
water no it's like man that'd be kinda
cool at the end and also I'm like I
don't need play by I don't need a
play-by-play of what happened and Empire
I mean these people if someone with
their brains like it doesn't like think
if they want to make an old ship work I
know it's the force but sometimes brains
yeah sometimes just little bugs in your
blood and it makes you live stuff up
midi-chlorians bugs
I think another theme attic parallel is
the idea of like this is the tragedy of
the three you know this is the one where
we see the characters in the most dire
conditions and I think the escape at the
Battle of Hoth is very similar to the
resistance being on the run and this is
you know the first order strikes back
essentially but I think this one did up
the ante I really maybe I grew up
knowing what I think I saw Return of the
Jedi before I saw the other two movies
so I knew the characters live to see
another day whereas in this movie I
don't know who's I you know I'm
experiencing it first time so I feel
more of that fear that I could lose one
of them there's a lot more secondary
characters in this current trilogy so
the stakes are a little bit higher there
as well instead of just knowing that
it's the trio and the two droids and a
sidekick yeah that's a Wookiee that's
Chewie
but I think one thing Empire definitely
has over it spiritual grandchild is this
idea of a wealthy corrupt neutral planet
they go to Cloud City versus Kanto bite
in this film the heroes get betrayed by
a character not whole this guy's like
Arya Beach and then they're like we're
arresting you for Parker on the beach
and then we go then hours later on horse
ride through the city where's the ship
on the beach that movie if
yeah I know rested people for parking
somewhere they weren't supposed to you
should move you should move the ship but
his point was it was a public beach I
know they were in a hurry but like
presumably there's a space valet right
no one knows why they're there like oh
we got to immediately arrest these
people they should just pulled it up for
the phone I did like Justin throw throw
the dice and I and I liked they had to
my favorite aliens in this area was the
screaming opera woman and then for a
second would a first alien you see when
you get into the casino is like a
mustache and he walks away and you never
see him again and I'm like it uh I'm
gonna dig this and then as the that
story when I'm like actually if knowing
you know what's happening right now in
the movie in a parallel universe we
actually sold them catch up with Justin
Theroux his character and we had him
instead of his character was he's a good
actor I liked his character because I
like that he is like a kind of a new
it's a it's definitely a more it's 34
years later or whatever think he's mine
of thinking of like he's the guy
explaining that we're in war it's really
kind of more convoluted than yeah
thinking like the way he shows like oh
this is an arms dealer looks like he
sells weapons to the first order oh look
he also sells x-wings like it's not as
clear-cut as you think yeah the people
on the first order like I could have
said that just as easily there yeah true
well beneath shows gonna Dax
yeah we're fun yeah yeah he's a good
show a there were problems actually I
thought when Benito was telling that
whole thing about the the arms dealers
it's just me but it felt like Rian
Johnson wrote a little dig at Disney
where it's like
yeah wars never end like Star Wars and
all workers get money on the side and
you're gonna watching all your favorite
characters die and die over and over
again and you're gonna buy it all sure
that's what I felt like it was but I
also like they have him he's like a
morally ambiguous guy I do think it was
a very Star Wars II thing of like he's a
master code breaker we kind of see him
do it and then it's never the plan yeah
I think one is like a gum wrapper in a
row I think one of the strengths
definitely the movie was the the Battle
of crate which also felt like the Battle
of Hoth and this white surfaced planet
with a Imperial walkers that's a t-80s
it's all it's all wood you to catch
Gareth Edwards rogue one director was a
guy he was talking to he kind of gave
him that stink eye like a Star Wars
cameo you should care about because the
Cameron great if it was like oh it's
salt and everyone looks and then it cuts
to everyone in Empire Strikes Back or
sorry it's no planet
hahaha sorry all those actors they turn
on the snow planets like see it's not
snow no it's to cure and I love the the
alteration by having this red mineral
base underneath the ground it's like the
red the color red was so interesting too
vibrant in this movie where there was
snoke's like throne room or this battle
we saw it in the trailers but just like
we're touring Kurds like I love the the
color schemes is I can't wait to break
it down in the video and in a breakdown
I'm gonna do this go do that go to my
hole we can we kind of agree that this
movie's just a tad long it's a test when
you get to the final part of like them
escaping you're like wait a minute they
haven't been
planet yeah and you're like oh oh no we
have to have a whole store on the planet
again love this movie I really liked it
but I'm like I thought this movie flowed
way faster than force awakens I said
religions in the third time that I saw
force awakens which is too much for an
adult I had to like go take breaks like
okay I've seen this sequence before this
movie I was like it is long I won't
disagree with you but I thought in terms
of pacing it moved it clicked along well
this question of how complex and busy
overall the movie is it sets us up for
our next segment pretty well this is uh
let's look at the last time I buy the
numbers and number I'm most interested
in to talk about is 125 that is the
number of physical sets built for the
last Jedi by its production crew the
script originally called for a hundred
and sixty sets to be built producers of
course scaled that down it's way more
than any other film for sure
Lucas George Lucas said in an interview
that while visiting the Pinewood Studios
said he was confused poetry he's yeah
he's shot pretty much all this prequels
on green-screen
I remember this it's technically we
learned this in a past need to know
holds the record for the most planets
shown on screen one movie because he
just built them all in post-production
during that order execute order 66
montage beautifully that looks like a
gaffer in the background tape it's just
a curtain in the movie so really dick on
fire there's all windows it's like why
did you but this is not good this is not
function well do we think that the movie
was too busy do you think there was too
many places or do you think that
tactility helps no that is a calculated
move by the studio to keep the movie
fast enough for little kids to watch it
and not get bored because they're
already not gonna know
and what's going on and like every Star
Wars fan they're gonna have to watch
these movies 20 times before they
finally fully grasp but at least in this
movie like every 5 minutes they're like
a new thing going on another fight
another weapon another toy I potentially
want that's really what it I think
that's I mean the kid plays with Luke
Skywalker actions II maybe it's ryan
Johnson he knows what that he knows the
behind the scenes he's trying to show
you yeah I think there's this term that
I've heard in screening I don't know
it's a term it's just this concept and
screenwriting that in movies you should
never have your characters go backward
and return to a place unless it's for
some kind of thematic reason they should
go to a new place every time because
that old place they cannot return to
they're on their journey they have to
keep moving forward or they'll die kind
of like a shark I guess I think this
movie did that really well literally
characters are moving forward the whole
time even if it's just out of the blast
radius range of the supremacy some are
moving very slowly forward some are
moving very quickly forward I don't know
I think there's just if the movie felt
like a six-hour HBO miniseries to me it
felt like there's so much time in the
movie and I loved walking out feeling
like I had a good robot Star Wars meal
so long and provide so much like it
really answered the biggest questions so
quickly yeah question no it does not
seem to me like 125 sets were built it
didn't I didn't be like yeah that sounds
about right no I was like well I find it
surprising that was I only counted 120
will do another count yeah okay let's
move on guys to our need to know
lightning round
you guys were so great to tweet us in
your question Emperor Palpatine
electrifies these a bit right it was
just like a little zap taste don't tase
me bro I knew that guy claim to fame
it's knowing don't tase me bro okay so
we're gonna read these you guys have to
answer as quickly as possible here we go
in three two one
Tommy bottom-line Bechtold if you came
with a warning label what would it be
from Lillie Mae's rated pg-13 with
language in one scene of sensuality
wonderful Maude Garrett a Momo wants to
know what is your favorite game of
Thrones house Oh
Tyrell has two Tyrell they're up on the
hill in the gardens and they have ranked
the Star Wars movies also for Momo Oh
for me yeah this last Jedi and I just
want people to hate me now episode three
two one and then [ __ ] Christmas special
than four six five rogue one that's an
honest review that one's trash hurt look
at this pain I want people mad now I'm
mad about the Yoda thing I wanna go for
me who wrote this
Oh Jacob wants to know what's my
favorite character in the last Jedi guys
I gotta go with that lounging milk thing
8:8 teats I would only be lounging in
the Sun well make sure for future
episodes that the need to know tweet us
at new rockstars hashtag need to know
with your a question me too Momo okay
let's take a look in our next segment
here what we got in the pipeline what's
coming out on this channel next week as
I mentioned at some point I will be
coming out of my forced cave to release
this full movie this again and I kind of
want to do a separate video that just
talks about Leia in this movie I had so
many questions about her I'm really
interested to like think deeply might
have with like a great explanation for
Holloway was able to use that power I
want to look into that and and also how
Carrie Fisher was worked in in this
movie for me at some stage in your video
can you say Leia never met off words
that end in ER is like I never met it's
it's run its course we also have a video
about this big Disney Foxx murderer
really but I also wrote the video I
worked on it was a lot of fun it's all
it's the potential of what we could get
in these movies now and a half maybe not
so much how everything could work in
because that's up to the writers and
honestly you guys did that job you wrote
every fan theory possible but this is
actually the potential now from
storylines in the comics like maybe
storming Black Panther getting together
that's a very popular marriage in the
comics and there's more from that so
check out the video how you address the
five to ten thousand jobs that are
probably being lost they're just being
outsourced from the Human Torch is gonna
hang out VFX artists in China with
Captain America
yeah also guys we're continuing our game
of thrones rewatched series i got a
breakdown in the works for season 1
episode 5 remember that is the lion and
the wolf really really fun episode I
know each episode kinda had some
interesting insights but this one in
particular had some it has what I think
is one of the best scenes of the series
between Robert and Cersei where we never
really see them connect this is a one
scene it's such a well written grounded
scene where both characters are
humanized in such an interesting way and
yeah we got Sam has a ready player one
breakdown the new trailer and we're on
it yeah battle scene was that black mice
for Maz huh who was the rat next and
we'll have a ton more fun into viewer
videos and things that connect some
things for you guys to round out the end
of the year but now comes the time for
our 15-second shout-out where each of us
have 15 seconds to shout out plug
rambled out anything we want Sam
well why don't you take it away well if
I saw Coco and I think everyone should
go see it it's the I think the last
really really good Pixar movies I like
inside that's really good but the one
that got me last was Toy Story 3 and
this is that's that same tear now it's
an amazing movie the music is amazing go
watch it you will weep constantly yeah
the need to Coco was what we should call
this the okay so my 15 second shot out
there is a video that is kind of going
viral of opening night of last rally
last night I was taken right down the
road from here at the AMC 16 in Burbank
California of there was no audio to play
during the movie people lost their mind
started yelling at staff is it restarted
restarted I almost went to that theater
I was almost at that screen it was at
the same time I saw it just at a
different theater it's definitely worth
watch yes you may
and I know all the dirty secrets about
him now Wow my 15 seconds is to the
security team with the El Capitan
Theatre last night that accidentally
turned the lights on during the movie
for five minutes which didn't bother me
at all because I'm a reasonable person
that understands humans make mistakes
were you there caused everyone to get
their money back the same screening the
lights or not and then anyone who asked
for it they just gave them their money
back it always makes me feel guilty
because I did not enjoy the movie any
less because of it but I was like and
this is $28 less now did you I did I did
so thanks to that that was like 25
seconds and inappropriate joke just
started off so alright we are now
returning to our trivia question that we
asked earlier I just remind you guys
what it was in Star Wars episodes 1
through 7 and rogue one name the
character who spoke the line I have a
bad feeling about this
in movie do we have our answer yeah I
have sweet baby T so read them out and
just check it off ok ok here we go
in episode 1 Phantom Menace obi-wan
Kenobi says it I believe it is the first
line of the movie I have a bad feeling
about this too - qui-gon jinn episode 2
it is Anakin Skywalker that may have
been in the arena right when he's
strapped up against it yeah episode 3 we
got obi-wan Kenobi again
yeah I liked my answer as my answer Jedi
kid with Anakin went when Anakin walks
in with lights broke one I remember this
at k2s oh that was the fun where he gets
cut off a new hope a Luke says it Luke
and Han actually say if you have yeah or
you get one point for each if you get
them if you wrote down both you get in
episode 5 of Empire Strikes Back it was
Leia who says it Ronald Reagan six yeah
return to the Jedi c-3po and Han say the
different points my dad
Sam reckoned it was an Ewok while he's
eating the person he's like I'm saying I
got mad and then recently in the force
awakens we had Han Solo so we don't know
do we all guess episode a because I did
and Tommy did yeah I I guess when you
say Eric guest port mama
remember that mama tommy said craft
services - Ricky vas got five out of
seven whoo Maude Garrett got six out of
sweet baby t he got four mix Maude our
winner oh damn
who's got that coming alright so as
always are the winner will do our
goodbyes modest or wonder we'll get to
do any funny voice or crazy character
she wants to do difference table was
character I'm so excited
but first Sammy's gonna have to do our
in other news headlines we didn't have
time for as a loser trivia question he's
gonna have to read these and at the end
of each headline you have to make a if
the riff or do some joke
to cleverly parity to headline in some
way thing all right well here we go with
number one NASA confirmed that Star Wars
the last Jedi will be screamed for
astronauts orbiting Earth on the
International Space Station I promise
you guys that was about three million
dollars in tax dollars that went to
those nerds watching a movie in space
number two Disney confirmed its buyout
of Fox's TV and film properties Disney
now owns 39% of the entertainment
industry I'm fine with because I I
actually love this news yeah we're gonna
buy a joke and it's coming and here it
comes it's coming down the pipe and here
comes and it's number three Woody
Harrelson is in talks to join the cast
of venom rumored to be under
consideration to play the part of
carnage that's real cool that's scary
man ain't allowed in most stores so
he'll play a grazing I didn't hear it
it's probably better than what I said I
don't think we can repeat it for
stranger things in it star finned
wolfhard was cast as Billy Batson in the
upcoming DC movies Shazam the queue
didn't exactly buzz didn't the other kid
get kissed or did a new kid get cast I'm
on team will well team in old headline
yeah maybe he you know how bad I'm
sweating right now cuz I'm really
failing at this that's the joke I'm the
joke and number five ready player one
author Ernest Cline confirmed that a
sequel novel is in the works
title ready player two
about the absolute slew of abuse that
he's been getting for his riding like
that's a lot I don't know was it from
all these titles are too confusing
am I just overthinking it or the assists
from every one of the tables hey we're
here we got your back yeah thank you for
watching this week's episode oh I want
to thank our who's Sam Basha at Sam or
Garrett at Maude Garrett Antonio
Bechtold
I told you once I've told you a thousand
times wonderful now for those
battlefront to details they've been so
patiently waiting on oh we got some free
copies about affront to that we're dying
to give away to you guys all you have to
do is follow us on twitter at new
rockstars find our recent tweet about
the amazing battlefront to break down
that we do in this channel retweet it
that's all you gotta do and then we'll
have a list of you and we'll contact you
you'll be in a you'll be entered into a
pool that will be randomly selected but
yeah guys get on this like it's free
it's yeah and a quick other shout out if
you really loved all the the lightsaber
action and smoothie because I really
really do love I can't wait to talk
about more in the breakdown we did at a
separate video with me and Phillip
learning the various lightsaber fighting
styles with swordplay we brought in a
new a real sword fighting expert it was
one of those fun times I had doing a
video and we learned some stuff about
Star Wars in universe 7 different forms
and they're all based on real world
sword fighting equivalents yeah
sucks Ian yeah he projects it back which
is why embers like yeah yeah check that
check out that video comment down below
and tweet us at new rock stars using the
hashtag need to know like this video
share it around subscribe to new rock
stars with deep dives in the stuff you
love guys see you next week